[Music]
foreign
[Music]
do you enjoy it when they deserve it did
they deserve it today
I'm not sure but you did it anyway yeah
just like the half dozen guys you're
screwed today
well actually it was only two
you're different officer why
you're the first man in five years who
didn't tell me I look like Veronica Lake
inside of a minute
better than Veronica Lake
since the 1930s of classic hitchcocking
Thrillers the murder mystery genre is
grown in size and popularity more lies
more twists and of course more murder Mr
my family will pay cash whatever Ransom
you're asking for they'll pay it
rubs the lotion on its skin or else it
gets the hose again
now while True Crime content has seen a
rise in its audience it's also
introduced a new generation to the
whodunit scene pushing each of these
movies to be more complex in intricacies
than the last
am I doing
I'm chasing this guy
no he's chasing me for this list we're
including titles with at least 10
reviews and that we're ranked highest by
Tomato Meter so keep your friends close
and your enemies closer as we count down
our list of the best murder mystery
movies
[Music]
number 10 zodiac
in the late 1960s and 1970s fear grips
the city of San Francisco as a serial
killer called zodiac stocks its
residents investigators and reporters
become obsessed with learning the
Killer's identity and bringing him to
Justice meanwhile zodiac claims victim
after victim and taunts the authorities
with cryptic messages ciphers and
menacing phone calls starring Jake
Gyllenhaal Mark Ruffalo Robert Downey Jr
and directed by David Fincher critics
say a quiet dialogue driven Thriller
that delivers with scene after scene of
gut-wrenching anxiety David Fincher also
spends more time illustrating nuances of
his characters and recreating the mood
of the 70s than he does on gory details
of murder and zodiac
son
we are not treasuring these calls you
have my word
okay
Sam you need to tell me what your
problem is I don't want to go to the gas
chamber I have headaches I kill I don't
get them yes
you want to live don't you
well this is your passport how long have
you been having these headaches I killed
a kid
do you have blackouts
do you have fits no I
headaches did you attempt to call one
other time when F Lee Bailey was with us
two or three weeks ago
and why did you want to talk to Mr
Bailey why do you want to talk to me Sam
I don't want to be here
you won't get hurt if you talk to me
you're not going to the gas chamber
I wouldn't think they would ask for
capital punishment
number nine memento
Leonard is tracking down the man who
raped and murdered his wife the
difficulty however of locating his
wife's killer is compounded by the fact
that he suffers from a rare untreatable
form of memory loss although he can
recall details of life before his
accident Leonard cannot remember what
happened 15 minutes ago where he's going
or why starring Guy Pierce carrion Moss
Joe pontoliano and directed by
Christopher Nolan critics say
Christopher Nolan skillfully guides the
audience through memento's fractured
narrative seeping his film in
existential dread
Teddy
don't believe his lies he is the one
kill him I finally found him how long
have I been looking
find anything
didn't think so
let's go huh
you're gonna pay for what you did Big
forgiveness
you know clue you freak beg my wife's
forgiveness
before I blow your brains out damn it
you don't know what's going on you don't
even know my name Teddy that's cause you
read it off a [ __ ] picture
you don't know who you are I'm Leonard
Shelby I'm from San Francisco
you want to know Lenny
come on
come on let's go down the basement
cool down you were made together
then you'll know who you really are
no
number eight The Silence of the Lambs
Jody Foster stars as Clarice Starling a
top student at the FBI's Training
Academy Jack Crawford wants Clarice to
interview Dr Hannibal Lecter a brilliant
psychiatrist who is also violent
psychopath serving life behind bars for
various acts of murder and cannibalism
Crawford believes that Lecter may have
insight into a case and that Starling is
an attractive young woman maybe just the
bait to draw him out starring Jody
Foster Anthony Hopkins Scott Glenn and
directed by Jonathan Demi critics say
director Jonathan Demi smart taught
Thriller the Silence of the Lambs
Teeters on the edge between
psychological study and all-out horror
and benefits greatly from Stellar
performances by Anthony Hopkins and Jody
Foster I've read the Case Files have you
everything you need to find him is right
there in those pages and tell me how
principles Clarice simplicity
read Marcus Aurelius of each particular
thing ask what is it in itself
what is its nature
what does he do this man you seek
no that is incidental
what is the first and principle thing he
does what needs does he serve by killing
anger
um
social
Acceptance in sexual frustrations no
he covets
is nature
and how do we begin to covet Clarice
do we seek out things to covet
make an effort to answer now
no
we just
now we begin by coveting what we see
every day don't you feel eyes moving
over your body Clarice
and don't your eyes seek out the things
you want
your son in a small South Korean town
a living selling medical herbs mother
and son are plunged into a nightmare
when the body of a murdered young girl
is discovered circumstantial evidence
indicates the sun's involvement and he
becomes the prime suspect during the
sloppy police investigation betrayed by
the legal system the mother takes the
lawn to her own hands to clear her son's
name starring Kim hey ja Juan bin Jin
goo and directed by bang Jun ho critics
say as fleshly as it is funny bong Joon
Ho's mother straddles family drama
horror and comedy with a Deft grass book
tone and plenty of eerie visuals
foreign
foreign
[Music]
number six the big sleep
private investigator Philip Marlow is
hired by General sternwood to help
resolve the gambling depths of his wild
young daughter Carmen now sternwood's
older daughter Vivian provides
assistance when she implies that the
situation is more complex and also
involves casino owner and a recently
disappeared family friend as people link
to the sternwood start being murdered
Marla finds himself getting ever deeper
into the case starring Humphrey bogar
Lauren Bacall Martha Vickers and
directed by Howard Hawks critics say a
perfect match of screenplay director and
leading man the Big Sleep stands as a
towering achievement in film Noir whose
Grim Vitality remains undim you want to
know what I've got her don't you I don't
know
200 buys a lot of information in my
circle would you pay it to know where
Eddie Ma's wife is would you pay 200
bucks for that Sheamus
I think I might
wear Agnes found her she'll tell you
when she has the doll in her hand
you might tell a cop for nothing I ain't
so brittle Agnes must have something I
didn't notice I ain't tried to pull
anything if I came here with a straight
proposition take it or leave it one
right guy to another
you start waving cops at me
you ought to be ashamed of yourself I am
okay 200 it is have you got the money
where's Agnes you know plus Walgreens
office full wider building 428 in the
back oh but I can find it would you be
in shape to meet me there in an hour
yeah I guess so you bring the doll and
I'll take you to Agnes okay okay
number five rashamon
brimming with action while incisively
examining the nature of Truth rashmon is
perhaps the finest film ever to
investigate the philosophy of Justice
through an ingenious use of camera and
flashbacks Kurosawa reveals the
complexities of human nature as four
people recount different versions of the
story of a man's murder and the rape of
his wife starring toshiro mifuni makiko
Kio Takashi shimura and directed by
Akira Kurosawa critics say one of
legendary director Akira kurosawa's most
acclaimed films rashmon features an
Innovative narrative structure brilliant
acting and a thoughtful exploration of
reality versus perception
foreign
[Music]
foreign
number five rear window
a newspaper photographer with a broken
leg passes time recuperating by
observing his neighbors through his
window he sees what he believes to be a
murderer and decides to solve the crime
himself with the help of his nurse and
wife he tries to catch the murderer
without being killed himself starring
James Stewart Grace Kelly Wendell Corey
and directed by Alfred Hitchcock critics
say Hitchcock exerted full potential of
suspense in this masterpiece
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's he trying to do why don't you
turn him in she's a smart girl smart
girl she'll get herself arrested I'll
get her out of there
look the wedding ring
[Music]
turn off the light itself
number three LA Confidential
three policemen each with his own
motives and obsessions tackle the
corruption surrounding an unsolved
murder at a downtown LA coffee shop in
the early 1950s detective Lieutenant
Exley the son of a murder detective is
out to avenge his father's killing now
the ex-partner of Officer white
implicated in a scandal rooted out by
Exley was one of the victims Sergeant
Vincent feeds classified information to
a tabloid magnate starring Russell Crowe
Guy Pierce Kim Basinger and directed by
Curtis Hansen critics say top pacing
brilliantly dense writing and
oscar-worthy acting combined to produce
a smart popcorn friendly Thrill Ride in
LA Confidential Lewis listen to me was
she in the night out
did you kill her
he wanted Lewis to lose his Cherry but
that wasn't enough so things got out of
hand and you made her bleed she bled on
your clothes so you burned the clothes
told you that
listen to me
if that girl is still alive she's the
only chance you've got
to leave her someplace to sell her out
tell me where she is
yeah
what
right six where's the girl white I have
this under control
[Music]
what
109 Avalon Crown Corn house upstairs
number two Chinatown
when La private eye JJ Gettys is hired
by Evelyn mulray to investigate her
husband's activities he believes it is a
routine infidelity case now Jake's
investigation soon becomes anything but
routine when he meets the real Mrs
mulray and realizes he was hired by an
imposter Mr mulray's sudden death sets
giddies on a tangled trail of corruption
deceit and Sinister family secrets as
Evelyn's father becomes a suspect in the
case starring Jack Nicholson Faye
Dunaway John Houston and directed by
Roman Polanski critics say as bruised
and cynical is a decade that produced it
Chinatown benefits from Robert Town's
brilliant screenplay director Roman
polanski's Steady Hand and wonderful
performances from Jack Nicholson and
Faye Dunaway
who is she and don't give me that crap
about your sister because you don't have
a sister
I'll tell you
I'll tell you the truth
good what's her name
Catherine
Catherine who
she's my daughter
said I want the truth
he's my sister
she's my daughter and my sister my
daughter
I said I want the truth
he gave my sister and my daughter
come on please go back
oh God said keep her upstairs go back
my father and I
understand
or is it too tough for you
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Mystic River
when the daughter of ex-con Jimmy Marcus
is murdered two of his childhood friends
in the neighborhood are involved now
Dave a blue-collar worker was the last
person to see her alive while Sean a
homicide detective is heading up the
case as Sean proceeds with his
investigation Jimmy conducts one of his
own through neighborhood contacts now
eventually Jimmy suspects Dave is the
culprit and considers taking the Law
into his own hands starring Sean Penn
Tim Robbins Kevin Bacon and directed by
Clint Eastwood critics say anchored by
the exceptional acting of its strong
cast Mystic River is a sober drama that
unfolds in layers and conveys a tragedy
of its story with visceral power
last time you saw Dave
the last time I saw a day
yeah
big boil
damn while
yeah
Dave Boyle
that was 25 years ago going up this
street in the back of that car
[Music]
Jimmy
what did you do
thanks for finding my daughter's killer
Sean
it's only been a little faster
Gosford Park
Robert Altman one of America's most
Distinctive filmmakers Journeys to
England for the first time to create a
unique film Mosaic with an outstanding
ensemble cast set in the 1930s Gosford
Park brings a group of pretentious rich
and famous together for a weekend of
relaxation at a hunting Resort but when
a murder occurs each one of these
interesting characters becomes a suspect
starring Eileen Atkins Bob Balaban Alan
Bates and directed by Robert Altman
critics say a mixture of Upstairs
Downstairs clue and perceptive social
commentary Gosford Park ranks among
director Altman's best good evening this
is
oh yes
we haven't moved him I've gathered
everyone
don't worry about it
now I'll tell you who we all are and
then we can all go to bed maybe with
Paul Williams does that sound like a
good plan should I introduce myself I'm
inspector
oh it's the kind of Trenton me as I
served with your husband my
brother-in-law Lord Stockbridge lady
Stockbridge Jennings please would you
remove that vile animal
uh Mrs Nesbitt uh Mr Nesbitt I have a
novello but I'm sure need to know it
well of course wait wait would you
would you have servants tonight in
Spanish I think he ought to speak to
private my husband's about it would you
tell him to come up now where was I um
Isabel mccorded my daughter surely chair
is in London he's not in California
I mean they're trying to be our rewrites
about the part of the Cockney made and
she's running in and saying all these
things look I'm here they don't talk to
Butler's in the mains they stand they
watch I mean you know they serve they do
things
what about Claudette Colbert isn't she
she's British isn't she she sounds
British is she like affected or is she
British The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo
while these Swedish recluse Henrik
vanger needs closure 40 years ago his
beloved knees disappeared never to be
seen again and circumstances have led
him to believe that a member of his own
repugnant family must be responsible
venger hires stoic journalists Mikhail
Blomquist and Scrappy chain smoking
hacker Elizabeth Salander to come to his
Island dig deep into chilling family
secrets and unmask the killer once and
for all starring Michael Nyquist numi
rupaz Lena Andre and directed by Niels
Arden oplev critics say it's graphic
violence and sprawling length will prove
too much for some viewers to take but
numi rupasa's gripping performance makes
The Girl with the Dragon Tattoo an
unforgettable viewing experience
you want some water
thanks
you see
you're exactly like all the others
a simple Act of compassion like giving
you water ignites the smallest Ray of
Hope that maybe just maybe I might let
you go and that you'll live
see what I mean
[Music]
and finally number one Laura in one of
the most celebrated 1940s film noirs
Manhattan detective Mark McPherson
investigates the murder of Madison
Avenue executive Laura hunt in her
fashionable apartment on the trail of
her murderer McPherson quizzes Laura's
arrogant best friend gossip columnist
Waldo lydecker and her comparatively
mild fiance Shelby Carpenter as a
detective grows obsessed with the case
he finds himself falling in love with a
dead woman starring Gene Tierney Dana
Andrews Clifton Webb and directed by
Otto preminger critics say a
psychologically complex portrait of
obsession Laura is also a deliciously
well-crafted murder mystery
were you in love with Laura hunt Mr
leidega
is she in love with you
Laura consider me the wisest the
wittiest The Most Interesting Man she'd
ever met
I was in complete Accord with her on
that point
she taught me also the kindest the
gentlest
most sympathetic man in the world
did you agree with her there too
a person you won't understand this
but I tried to become the kindest
gentlest
the most sympathetic man in the world
have any luck
let me put it this way
I should be sincerely sorry to see my
neighbor's children devoured by wolves
should we go
well my friends that about that about
does it for us be sure to stay tuned to
the Rotten Tomatoes channel for more of
the entertainment content you love until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]